hi there steve kaufman here
um i'm in the home stretch now two weeks
to go in my 90-day polish challenge
i'm going to deal with two issues today
one is the issue of correcting mistakes
and the other issue is why do i do it
all right correcting mistakes i put up a
video of me speaking to my polish tutor
or one of my polish tutors
katarina again to put this in context
for the first two months i just listened
and read
increasingly difficult uh
content or rather
very easy content to start with
slowly mixing in more difficult content
and for the last month essentially just
authentic content
and then after two months
i started speaking so i have now spoken
uh once a day for about eight or nine
days so i put up one of my discussions
and someone commented that the tutor
wasn't correcting me and that this was
no good and so forth and so on so let me
be let me address this issue of
correcting
i when i speak with a tutor i don't want
to be corrected while i'm speaking i
make so many mistakes in my polish
that we couldn't have a conversation if
i were corrected every every five words
or every three words
uh what the tutor does
and this is the policy we have at link
is send me a list of the words and
phrases that i didn't use correctly or
at least some of them and then i read
this i import it into link i save words
and phrases it it helps a bit
but the biggest advantage of the
conversation is that i'm forced to use
the language so to search for words i
become aware
of where some of my gaps are my problems
and then i become that much more
attentive when i'm listening and reading
so it's all part of that gradual process
of getting used to the language i don't
think a correction corrects you i think
a correction
if if there are not too many corrections
and and particularly there are some
things that we just never notice if it's
not pointed out to us and so to that
extent the occasional correction is good
but most mistakes that we commit
we're going to correct them ourselves or
we'll make that error one time and we
won't make it the next time until we get
better and better at using the language
it's a gradual process it's so important
to speak and eventually to write if you
have the patience to do so
and it's the exercise of speaking and
participating in the conversation that's
most important the correction is
probably not that very important and
especially if it interrupts the flow of
the discussion
as to why i do these things i'm having a
blast with my polish i had a discussion
this morning we talked about politics i
understand podcasts now like rapporto
host
which i didn't understand six weeks ago
i've discovered a country and i can't
wait to move on to the next one i don't
take my language level to some kind of
level of perfection
i don't that's fine for those people who
want to do it
i'm not going to write a test to see if
i'm b2b1c1
that's not my motivation my motivation
is to discover new countries new
cultures new languages and you know i
enjoy doing it so that's my motivation
all right
thank you and we continue with the
polish challenge and we'll see i'll do
one more video of a discussion with a
polish uh tutor
at the end of my uh
90 day challenge bye for now